everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen hi poppy
[Music]
today i'm going to take you guys through
a day in the life of a full-time
youtuber and working mom very realistic
addition but first let me tell you about
my sponsor seed so i talk about the
importance of gut health all the time
and a lot of people ask me my opinion on
pre and probiotics so probiotics are the
good gut bacteria and prebiotics are the
food that feed the bacteria and both are
important for a healthy gut microbiome
so i like seeds ds01 daily synbiotic
because you get both a pre and a
probiotic in one capsule together with
24 clinically and scientifically studied
strains the way they've engineered their
two in one capsule ensures 100 delivery
of the probiotic to your colon so you'll
really reap the benefits most probiotics
end up dying in your stomach acid so if
you've taken a probiotic before and felt
no difference it's likely because it
just wasn't surviving the harsh
environments of our gi tract seed is
different in this regard so we have
evidence that a healthy gut with an
optimal balance of good bacteria can
help to support digestive issues and
promote overall systemic health like
eased bloating gut immune function heart
health skin health and so much more i
also really like that they are
sustainably delivered every month
because you get a refillable glass jar
with your first purchase and the monthly
refills are delivered in compostable
biodegradable and recyclable packaging
so if you want to check out seed for
yourself you can get 15 off of your
first month's supply of seeds ds-01
daily symbiotic by clicking the link in
the description box and using my code
abby at checkout but very quickly my
disclaimer that what you're gonna see is
just what i ate today this is not even a
typical day i don't eat the same thing
every day and this is not a suggestion
of what you should eat my needs are
always unique to me they're not a
representation of what i suggest for
anyone else so please do not try to
emulate my day if you're struggling
please speak to a healthcare provider
about your unique needs all right let's
get into our day all right one kid in
school the other one at a play date now
we work in silence
but first
coffee
all right so
basically
if i sound like
it's because i have slept
a few hours the past few nights my
husband is away so i'm responsible for
the early mornings and the middle of the
night wake ups just my son just will
call me out in the middle of the night
and saying hi mom what's wrong i just
wanted to talk and so then i have a hard
time getting back to sleep hashtag
insomnia problems uh so coffee is a must
uh it's not gonna help my voice but it's
definitely going to help me function so
i switch it up between like what kind of
milk i do today it's uh oat milk and i
also am adding this little almond and
coconut creamer because i'm into that
right now um
but the most important thing
is the caffeine so
let's grab a cup
let's not channel the winter today let's
do
vanity
and a shoe
goodness to catch you up to speed this
is what my morning looked like five
ish
we woke up i'm just gonna let that run
because
it's my favorite sound uh we did a
puzzle which then was destroyed by one
of the other one of the children a
little bit of lego
did some arts and crafts had some
breakfast with the kids i have had so
far just a coffee this is number two
and
a ton of water because like i said i
have not didn't get a good sleep last
night i wonder why
[Music]
and for the record i just drink regular
old tap water so no no freshly squeezed
lemon juice going into this no detox
concoctions it's just
regular old water and coffee
got the creamer just a little bit and
actually you know what
just because i feel like a little more
in my cup
i'm gonna do
a decaf shot too i have a very
complicated coffee regimen i'm just
gonna dump that
i'll fill it up i'll warm it up it'll
get cold i'll warm it up i get cold warm
cold warm cold just how we roll over
here
okay let's do something else breakfast
okay so if you've been following my sibo
sega you probably know that i take a lot
of supplements and it's absolutely been
helping um just a quick update i feel
like i'm in a good place with my sibo uh
my bloating has definitely reduced my
i'm much more regular than i was before
i feel very good on that front so if i
have to take
some supplements just to keep myself
stable i feel like it's well worth the
daily regimen to just avoid having to
start this whole process all over again
so that's my
morning
pack
do you think i can do it in one gulp i
think with your experience at this point
probably okay i feel like there's a lot
of pressure now
that's talent okay so i usually make a
smoothie
for my kids bedtime snack but if they
can do double duty and i can have some
too we love to see it so today's
smoothie is going to have okay ripe
banana
some frozen cherries
frozen mango
frozen spinach
a lot
of peanut butter
we like
lots in my house
that's gonna add protein it's gonna add
iron gonna add our fiber and healthy
fats and ditto for
you guys know
my favorite hemp herds we go through a
whole bag of hemp parts and a whole tub
of peanut butter every single week
just
mainly for making this smoothie
and then we just pray that we can fit it
all in
oh she's taking a little bit of time
sink down there baby girl always get a
little overzealous on
packing her in
all right
and this is a meal prep
favorite in my house made this on the
weekend during nap time
this is on my blog it is my zucchini
chocolate chip baked oatmeal it's got
chocolate chips obviously
oats peanut butter
ripe banana zucchini that i've grated up
maple syrup eggs did i say that and tons
of hemp hearts obviously
so it's a favorite
the kids get pretty excited about
anything that has chocolate chips on it
so
let's warm her up
oh my coffee
we love surprises we love caffeinated
surprises smells so good so i'm just
gonna do a little greek yogurt here
and i always get like the full fat stuff
it's so good
and
this is also a meal prep essentials for
us because we go through so much fruit i
can't be constantly washing it so
whenever i do like a fruit haul which is
about i don't know three times per week
in my house
i'll just
wash them as i have them and then
they're ready for the week these
raspberries are
getting a little smushed down there
all right most important part
the maple syrup
mama
give that strawberry some love yeah
tastes like cake how could you not like
this she thick that's how i like it damn
boy
so i got a super busy day i got to film
a few videos uh including this one
obviously uh so i gotta go get myself
ready and presentable for the day and i
do not know why i'm still wearing my
baseball cap inside okay if you guys
watched my hot take on the batgirl
movement you know i do not know what the
[ __ ] i'm doing when it comes to makeup i
just try to get it done as quickly as
possible and i know i'm really really
driving someone crazy by not putting my
hair back right now but again i'm
rushing and that's kind of how i do
things i just want to look borderline
presentable and know that that's
probably going to be enough that is the
motto of my life let's just be enough
good enough so
let's just speed this up and
see how quickly we can get this face on
now i gotta do some emails gotta write a
script
gotta do a zoom call and then
hopefully by then we get to have lunch
one and only alexa denise hardcore diet
while taking her popular hardcore
classes so if you want to learn a new
no-carb recipe
about that but i haven't tried them i'm
going to just like make put it off till
maybe later on okay i'll keep you
present to say like i tried them
i know i know i mean like dying it's
like i'm dying inside just uh to do it
as a team but i probably will cheat and
just try them myself later hey everyone
i'm abby sharp welcome to abby's kitchen
today's video we are going to be talking
about pre-diabetes and how to prevent it
from turning into type 2 diet
too fast even slow
[Music]
so i try to get a workout in the morning
but i've been with the kids since 5 30
normally my husband and i like switch
off first thing in the morning so i can
have a little bit of time to myself
but it hasn't happened today obviously
so i've got to do my weekly ama where i
answer people's questions on instagram
if you don't follow me on instagram hit
me up because i do an ama
every friday so it's really fun and
usually i take the opportunity to like
just move my body a little bit so i'm
not just sitting down the entire day so
let's answer some questions favorite
food that is a really tough one probably
right now because it changes all the
time i am loving
like a really good pastel vodka or some
kind of pasta with a nice creamy sauce i
always add a big bowl of burrata into
the end of my cooking when i do a pasta
dish and it just adds that
oomph
no one says no to varada under calories
is not
enough for
an active teenager never mind an
unactive teenager so let's be honest how
many non-influencers
actually cook
three meals a day from scratch because i
don't do that
ever but especially when my husband's
away and my priorities are keep the
children alive and
cook and clean are like down here so we
ordered greek last night one of our
faves
and i thought ahead
and i ordered myself an extra salad that
i could have today
in case i didn't feel like making
anything from scratch so i got that
um but obviously that's not really going
to be enough for me i think i'm gonna do
like a quick little egg wrap situation
so my rule of thumb with anything food
related is
if you're gonna do it once you might as
well make a big batch so you can enjoy
it for at least another day or another
meal so i'm chopping up these bell
peppers for now to put in my salad but
i'm also going to have them at dinner
tonight and while i have the cutting
board out i might as well also chop up
some broccoli that we are also going to
have at dinner
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
she feels like a winner
this is the moment of truth don't let me
down girl
don't let me do it oh
beautiful beaut
she was ripe for the eaten
what okay so tech tell me this are you a
scoop then slice or a slice than scoop
i've always done this the slice then
scoop
but my sister-in-law tells me i'm wrong
slice and scoop always always
okay so or or peel
well that's what i'm saying i don't do
the peel like you slice it like
sometimes i'll slice it and then and
then you peel that's risky like you put
it upside down that's risky it could
just smush on you love it
make the puns while they're making food
and stuff oh no that's the heart now
i'll just make the food
but isn't it excellent
get out of my house get out
got to deal with this mess but
wow let's do this
did they not send dressing or did i
actually talk accidentally toss it good
thing i've got my own
[Music]
[Music]
that curry ketchup mmm she just hits
different
should drip him
okay so i gotta go pick up the kiddo and
the first thing he asks me when i see
him is ma what'd you bring what's to
bring what'd you bring for a snack so i
usually have to bring a selection
because he wants to see
the full the full spread so i've got
some cucumbers
seaweed which is always a hit all the
kids love it got a piece of fruit and
a little cheese so
yeah i guess we have a bit of a hunger
crushing combo here
and um i don't want to fill him up too
much because if i do then he's not going
to eat dinner with me shortly after so
this is a good little snack just time
over all right i'm about to make my way
into civilization still dressed in my
work from home ensemble you'll notice
that i only ever
change my top and then live in
lululemons or like pj pants and
my dirty running shoes anyone else
all right supplement
time number two this one is a lot more
manageable
all right we are on the home stretch of
the day towards my 7 30 p.m bedtime
and
i don't want to cook i don't want to
cook a lot at least so
frozen pizza it is i know at least the
kids will eat it they won't scream they
won't cry
it'll be a good night
what do we have so let's take a look
sicilian sausage
might be spicy
might be tears
this
is
unlabeled which is
risky
oh that's probably also clean and
sausage
did we eat all the pepperoni as you can
see there is a ton of carbs ice no idea
why i'm keeping ice it's just icing
carbs in here and a little bit of like
ground meat
um
i think we're going with with the
sausage and we're just gonna hope for
the best i'm gonna tell the kids that
it's sweet i'm gonna tell the kids that
it's delicious
and
we're gonna cover it in vegetables
and make it a little bit more balanced
and turn it into a hunger crushing combo
let's do it all right so
frozen pizza going down
and just make sure this doesn't stick
and so to turn this into a hunger
crushing combo basically i just
i've got a rotisserie chicken we live
breathe and die by rotisserie chickens
they are a lifesaver in the week they go
in everything stir fries
salads soups sandwiches wraps
or pizza in this case so that's gonna be
our protein so a little bit of extra
chicken on top here
and then i've already chopped up some of
these vegetables so i've got some bell
peppers
again we might just leave some raw for
the kids to snack on and then for
families who get really stressed out at
meal time but their kid not trying
anything it's not something that you
even have to think about because you
know that they've basically had an
appetizer of really delicious colorful
antioxidant rich fiber rich veg so and
this is looking so good already
a little tomato action
i mean you could totally just leave this
as is but i feel like this is a great
way to expose your kids to
new flavors new colors new textures when
it's on uh food that they already love
and accept and eat so last things last
last things last is that i don't know
last things last i feel like we got to
put a little extra trees on here it's
got cheese don't get me wrong but my
kids will never say no to more cheese
you just want those toppings to like
peek out
from underneath their
voluptuous bed of
cheesy goodness
yes
[Applause]
let's bake oh she's hot oh dinnertime
this is heavy
all right while that's cooking i'm going
to just boil some
uh corn and i've got some chopped up
broccoli as well
i prefer
everything to be like grilled or roasted
because it's just going to add so much
more flavor but my kids like their
vegetables
boiled or steamed so i'm not going to
argue with that
they get them how they like them and i'm
not going to i'm certainly not going to
cook them twice
pizza
can i wait
pizza time so this is my little hack you
basically like steam your broccoli on
top of the corn
as it's cooking
so you get it all done in one go
she's ready for dinner so
i've just gotten used to eating
all my vegetables
semi-soft like a geriatric texture
but a little pinch of
flair to sell definitely makes
everything better
just makes a little more grown up and
you know what really makes things grown
up wine in a can
yeah when daddy's away mommy will play
[Music]
this better be good
i'm not going to complain about it it's
not bad not great but i'm not opening up
a full bottle for myself that would
probably be not a great idea
this smells so good
[Music]
i love the broccoli
gives a nice crunch
all right last supplements
of the day
well that one
oh it's getting too cocky there
and i also have a little scoop
sorry
just
junk
i also have a scoop of my sun fiber
which is
really important for my sibo but also
i've been having a strange situation
that i talked about in a previous vlog
where i'm occasionally waking up super
super hungry in the middle of the night
so i used to take my fiber in the
morning but now i'm taking it at night
just as
reassurance that i don't get too
ravenous in the middle of the night and
it impedes my sleep anyways
just
added to the list of challenges i
experience having a anxiety disorder
not bad and since again
i want to prevent myself from waking up
in the middle of the night and then
needing to go get a big snack
i do have a pretty substantial bedtime
snack every day so this is one of my
go-to's
got some peanut butter toast
a really good hearty bread
with lots of protein and fiber
locker room in there
part one
part two
cottage cheese
it's super high in protein
always keeps me pretty satisfied
and
it's also one of my favorite foods
lots of blackberries
mmm i'm obsessed with blackberries right
now and they're
so good right now
oh
just
wreck the camera
i like a little crunch so we do some
cereal right now i'm feeling the puffins
that's one of my faves and i baked these
cookies the other day and i feel like
this is probably the end of their life
so
we're gonna crumble them up they have
walnuts chocolate chips and like a
massive caramel
crater
basically if that's not a hunger
crushing combo i don't know what is
i'm excited cookie cookie cookies
one measly cookie
well folks that's all that i have for
you guys today if you like this video be
sure to give it the thumbs up leave me a
comment below if you'd like to see more
vlog content like this subscribe to the
channel and i'll see you next time on
abby's kitchen bye
[Music]